[Music]
well marriage is also on the minds of
Prince Harry and Megan Marco who are
tying the knot this May and now Megan
can cross one major thing off her to-do
list the royal bride-to-be has already
picked a top secret designer for her
wedding gown and has had a fitting at
Kensington Palace a source also reports
that Megan's close friend and stylist
Jessica Maroney is helping with a dress
and planning the wedding so we brought
so many princesses Jessica also helped
Megan pick out a dress in 2016 for an
episode of her show suits her character
Rachel was also tying the knot we are
picking out Rachel vanes wedding dress
one of my closest girlfriends is here
jessica Mulrooney who runs Kleinfelds in
toronto and she's helping me for the
royal wedding megan is said to want a
gown that is simple and elegant and
we've seen that jessica has an eye for
detail so this is a 9 con and it's
called a transformer dress so it's
basically two dresses in 100 they
realize there's an overskirt and then
it's kind of this dramatic skirt for
however you get married and then you can
kind of take it off and dance the night
away if you decide to do that yesterday
in Wales Megan and Harry showed us how
much they love being around kids our
source also says that Harry's niece and
nephew Prince George and Princess
Charlotte will be a pageboy and flower
girl in the wedding just like they were
for their aunt Pippa Middleton's I Do's
[Music]
you